with 13 seconds left westbrook will
shoot a three
off iron long rebound fields got it
veal for three he made it and he was
fouled
so they decided not to foul them they
end up fouling at the worst time
it's interesting bradley beal came off
of that he probably could have shot
decided to
pass it up and go to westbrook who is
not a good three-point shooter
they're unable to come up with the bad
bounce
offensive rebound and you foul him
trying to
bother it from behind that is the worst
case scenario oh
now it's interesting if we could get a
look at it you know they're trying to
get to step but they're probably going
to just try to switch everything so
try to outsmart it maybe screen your own
man let steph get an opening somehow
begins to trigger curry's got it
and a three and that will do it
so the wizards four point play by
bradley beal
the warriors were up three with 13
seconds left in the game
and they are unable to close it out and
there'll be a lot of head shaking
and the wizards get all those points
from the center spot
and they execute in the final 20 seconds
in the hit
and one three game the wizards pick up
their second consecutive win
on this road trip hugs between curry
and beale mutual respect curry finishes
with 32 points
missed that last three veal